the law of large numbers gives a precise
formal statement of the basic intuitive
idea that underlies probability theory
and in particular our interest in random
variables and their expectations their
means so let's begin by asking what the
mean means why are we so interested in
it for example if you roll a fair die
with heads with faces one through six
the mean value it's expected value is
three and a half and you'll never roll
three and a half because there is no
three and a half face so why do we care
about what this mean is if we're never
going to roll it and the answer is that
we believe that after many rolls if we
take the average of the numbers that
show on the dice that average is going
to be near the mean it's gonna be near
three and a half let's look at an even
more basic example we if it's a fair die
the probability of rolling a six as with
any other number is 1/6 and the very
meaning of the fact that the probability
of rolling a six is 1/6 is that we
expect that if you roll a lot of times
if you roll about n times the fraction
of sixes is going to be around and over
six the fraction of six is going to be
about one-sixth that of n rolls you'll
get about n over six sixes that's that's
almost the definition or the intuitive
idea behind what we mean when we assign
probability to some outcome it's that if
we did it repeatedly the fraction of
times that it came up would be equal to
its probability or at least closely
equal to it in the long run
so let's look at what Jacob Bernoulli
who is the discoverer of the law of
large numbers had to say on the subject
he was born in 1659 died in 1705 and his
famous book the art of guessing are as
konjac Tandy was actually published
posthumously by his cousin and he said
Bernoulli says even the stupidest man by
some instinct of nature per se and by no
previous instruction this is truly a
knows for sure that the more
observations that are taken the less the
danger will be of straying from the mark
all right what does he mean well like
it's what we said a moment ago if you
roll the fair die n times and the
probability of a roll of is 1/6 then the
average number of sixes which is the
number of sixes rolled divided by n we
believe intuitively that that number is
gonna approach 1/6 as n approaches
infinity
that's what Bernoulli is saying that
everybody understands that they
intuitively are sure of it and who knows
how they figure that out but that's what
everyone thinks and he might be right
now of course when you're doing this
experiment of rolling n times and
Counting the number of six and seeing if
the fraction is close to 1/6 you might
be unlucky and it's possible that you'd
get an average that actually was way off
1/6 but that would be unlucky and the
question is how unlikely is it B is it
to be that you'd get a number of a
fraction of sixes that wasn't really
close to 1/6 and with the law of large
numbers is getting a grip on that and in
fact subsequently we'll get a more even
quantitative grip on it which will be
crucial for applications in sampling and
hypothesis testing but let's go on so
let's look at some actual numbers which
I calculated if you roll a die n times
where n is 6 6600 1,200 3,000 or 6,000
the probability that you're going to be
within 10% of the expected number of
sixes is given here so it turns out of
course that in order to be within 10 if
you're gonna roll six times the only way
to be within 10% of the one expected six
that you should roll is to roll exactly
one six in six tries and the probability
of that is about 40% point four as you
can check yourself easily then it turns
out that if you flip a roll
60 times
probability of being between 66 sorry
the expected number in 60 rolls is going
to be 10 so the probability of there
being within 10 percent of 10 or 9 to 11
sixes is 0.26 and likewise the
probability of there being within 10
percent of 100 which is the expected
number of sixes when you roll 600 times
is 0.72 and so on until finally the
probability of being within 10 percent
of a thousand which is the expected
number when you roll 6,000 times that is
between 900 and 1106 is in 6,000 rolls
is point nine nine nine triple nines in
fact it's a little bit bigger so it's
really only about one chance in a
thousand that your number of sixes won't
fall in that interval within ten percent
of the expected number well suppose I
asked for a tighter tolerance and I'd
like to know what's the probability of
being within five percent well first of
all notice of course that as the number
of rolls get larger the probability of
being in this given interval is of
getting getting higher and higher which
is what Bernoulli said and what we
intuitively believe the more rolls the
more likely you are to be close to what
you expect if you tighten the tolerance
of course then the probabilities wind up
getting smaller that you'll do so well
so if you want to be within 5% of the
average in six rolls it means you still
have to roll exactly 1/6 which means the
probability is still 0.4 but if you're
trying to be within 5% of the expected
number 10 and 60 rolls meaning between 5
and 15 that probability is only 0.14
compared to the probability of 0.26 of
being within 10% and if we jump down
here say to 3,000 rolls
the probability of being within 10% of
500 which is the expected number in
3,000 roles within 10% is 98% 9 8 but
within being within 5% of 500 it's 0.78
or about 3 little over 3/4 so what does
that tell us well it means that if you
enrolled three thousand times and you
did not get within ten percent of the
expected number of 500 that is you did
not get in the interval between 450 and
550 sixes you could be 98% confident
that your die is loaded it's not
weighted 1/6 to show a 6 and similarly
if you did not get within 425 and for
525 a 6 is in 3,000 rolls you can be 78%
sure that your die is loaded and this is
exactly why the law of large numbers is
so important to us because it allows us
to do an experiment and then assess
whether what we think is true is
verified by the outcome that we got in
this experiment all right let's go on to
see what else Bernoulli was concerned
with in his time it certainly remains to
be inquired whether after the number of
observations has been increased the
probability of obtaining the true ratio
finally exceeds any given degree of
certainty or whether the problem has so
to speak its own asymptotes that is
whether some degree of certainty is
given which one can never exceed now
that's a 17th century English that maybe
a little bit hard to parse so let's
translate it into math language what is
it that Bernoulli is asking so what
Bernoulli means is that he wants to
think about taking a random variable R
with an an expectation or mean of mu and
he wants to make n trial observations of
R and take the average of those
observations
and see how close they are to you all
right what is it what is making any
trial observations mean well formally
the way we're gonna capture it is we're
gonna think of having um a bunch of
mutually independent identically
distributed random variables r1 through
RN this phrase identically independent
identically distributed comes up so
often that there's a standard
abbreviation iid random variables so
we're going to have n of them and think
of those as being the n observations
that we make of a given random variable
on so r1 through RN each have exactly
the same distribution is our and they're
mutually independent and again since
they're they have identical
distributions they all have the same
mean mu as the random variable R that we
were trying to investigate so we model n
independent trials repeated trials by
saying that we have n random variables
that are iid okay now what Bernoulli is
proposing is that you take the average
of those n random variables so you take
R 1 through some of our 1 or 2 up
through R and then divide by n that's
the average value call that a sub n the
average of the n observations of the n
roll's
and Bernoulli's question is is this
average probably close to the mean mu if
n is big what exactly does that mean
probably close to MU means that the
probability that the distance between
the average and mu is less than or equal
to Delta is what so Delta is talking
about how close you are
don't they as a parameter we expect it's
got to be positive we're asking think of
whatever close means to you does it mean
0.1 does it mean point o 1 what amount
would persuade you that um that the
average was close to what it ought to be
and we ask then whether the distance
between the average and the mean is
close less than or equal to Delta and
Bernoulli wants to know what is the
probability of that
and what he goes on to say is therefore
this is the problem which I now set
forth and make known after I have
pondered it pondered over it for 20
years both its novelty and its very
great usefulness coupled with its great
difficulty can exceed in weight and
value all the remaining chapters of this
thesis now Bernoulli was right on about
the usefulness of this result at least
in its quantitative form and at the time
it was really pretty difficult for him
it took him like 200 pages to complete
his proof in ARS konjac tandy nowadays
we are going to do it in about a lecture
worth of material and you'll be seeing
that in some subsequent video segments
so that's what happens with 300 years
two or three hundred and fifty years to
tune up a result what took 200 pages
then now takes 10 or less pages in fact
if it was really concise it could be
done in a few in three pages alright so
again coming back to Bernoulli's
question Bernoulli's question is what is
the probability that the average that
the distance between the average and the
mean is less than or equal to Delta as
you take more and more tries as n goes
to infinity and Bernoulli's answer to
the question is that the probability is
1 that is if you want to be have a
certain degree of certainty of being
close to the mean within though if you
take enough trials you can be as certain
as you want that you'll be as close as
you want and that is called the weak law
of large numbers and it's one of the
basic transcendent rules and theorems of
probability theory it's usually stated
in the other way as that the limit of
the probability that the average is a
distance away from the mean Delta is 0
it's the probability that it's it's
extremely unlikely it can be as unlikely
as you want to make it that it's more
than any given tolerance from the mean
as if you take a large enough number of
trials now in this form it's not yet
really use
this is a romantic qualitative limit
limiting result and to really use it you
need to know something rather about the
rate at which it approaches the limit
which is what we're going to be seeing
in a subsequent video and in fact the
proof of this is going to follow easily
from the chebyshev inequality bound and
variance properties when we go about
trying to get the quantitative version
that explains the rate at which the
limit is approached